Or just do a full regex.
Yeah, exactly.
Just make it regex.
We can all write regex, you know?
Default to regex, please.
Yeah.
If you can't write regex, you need to go fix that.
What's up, y'all?
Before we hop into this episode, I just wanted to remind you
that we launched the Critical Thinking Discord community
a couple weeks back.
And ever since we did, it's been pretty much a constant stream
of hacking stories, exploitation techniques, cool research,
tool devs in there talking about features
and taking feature requests.
So it's been a really great community.
I've personally learned a lot already, and I think you will too.
So definitely check that out if you haven't already.
It's at ctbb.show slash discord.
And for those of you that are interested in supporting the podcast,
you can become a subscriber on Discord.
There's a $25, $10, and $5 subscription,
which gives you access to various benefits ranging from private scripts
and unredacted bug reports and what else?
Masterclasses that would be at the critical thinker tier,
the top tier, all the way down to a supporter badge at the lowest tier.
So if you're interested in supporting the pod,
that's the best way to do it.
All right.
With that, ctbb.show slash discord.
I'll see you there.
Enjoy the episode.
Yo, what's up, dude?
Yo, yo.
How's it going?
Good.
Just got done with my nice little pre-podcast little bounce,
little warm-up.
Ready to...
You seem to always forget that you're three hours ahead of me.
Yeah.
It's like 7.15 in the morning for you right now.
Something like that.
Well, thanks for getting up early to record the pod.
I wanted to start today off with a little bug bounty struggle story.
You know?
Yeah.
Because I feel like a lot of the people that listen to this pod,
you know, I hear a lot of...
Or at least what we see on the Discord often is, you know, people saying
there's a lot of struggles to bug bounty and that's true.
But it seems like, you know, everyone's just sort of at the top winning, winning,
winning, you know, posting there.
I just got awarded whatever bounty on whatever on Twitter, right?
Yeah.
But I wanted to flip it around a little bit today and give you guys a little bit
of an insight into the actual hacking struggles.
So this goes back to, I guess, the past two live hacking events that I've been a part
of.
The one in Tokyo and the one in Portugal.
And so I just barely scraped into the top 10 in Tokyo, which is great.
That was my goal.
But I think I placed like fourth or fifth in Portugal.
But both of those events for me were like a little bit subpar as far as like bounties
go, right?
As far as like actual earnings go.
And even though, you know, I was ranking pretty well on them, it was a little bit rough.
And so, and around this time, you know, I'm traveling all around Japan.
I'm traveling all around Portugal.
And I get back to my home and I'm like, man, I feel so disconnected from the hacking.
You know, like I haven't had like a normal schedule where I've deep dived something in
a long time.
And I just feel like that, you know, that difficulty getting restarted again.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
I mean, you're pretty like, I feel like you do hunting in spurts, right?
Do you also feel that sort of like stress when you haven't been hacking in a while and you
have to restart?
Yeah.
I mean, I feel that a lot.
Like I don't hack nearly as much as you do.
And so like that is kind of like an all the time struggle for me where like if I have
stopped hacking for a while and I need to get back into it, it's very difficult for me
to like get that ball rolling again.
Usually I'd either need somebody who I'm like hacking with who like has the energy going
already.
Like you're usually a good source of that.
Or I'll have to like just, you know, kind of like anything else that's really difficult.
You just have to like start on it.
Like how do you eat an elephant one bite at a time?
So it's the same thing with any other hard task that's like difficult to start.
You just have to start it and eventually like you'll get into it.
And usually like especially because it's something that we enjoy, like we'll fall into flow state
or something.
But you really just have to start.
And that's always like the hardest thing is just like starting with no sort of like,
you know.
Yeah, exactly.
And that's that's kind of where I was at this time, man.
And like this one actually really was hard for me to push through.
Like normally it's not very hard for me to push through.
And normally I'll just be like, you know, all right, time to just get back at it.
But this time I was like, man, I just I don't know what target to go after.
I don't know what like I was just kind of lost, you know.
But just like you said, you know, you just kind of you pick a target and you and you deep
dive it.
And then here's the thing, man.
Here's the thing that was crazy.
I went four days, which is like not super irregular for me, but I was feeling it a little,
you know, I was feeling the pressure a little bit.
I went four days without finding a bug.
Right.
Zero bugs for four days.
And that like, you know, when you're already feeling down in the dumps and you're like,
you're already feeling that the that the ambition is not there, that the motivation is not there.
That's just, you know, it's like like a knife in the chest and twist it.
You know, I will say this is normal for me because like oftentimes when I look at programs,
I'll be looking at like a lot of times mobile stuff.
And yeah, lots of programs are not mobile bugs.
Like it's just like either a very small app or it's just like, you know, small tech surface,
whatever.
And like I'll spend like a day like a whole day just like digging, looking at all the
different things like following paths down rabbit holes that don't lead anywhere.
And then just like by the end of it, I'm like, okay, well, I know a little bit more than I did
earlier, but that's about it.
Yeah.
And, and, and, but you know, that's, that's the way you got to start, right?
Like that's the way you got to get into it because yeah.
And I don't know.
So like after those four days, I was like, man, I feel like shit, but it's Friday and
I'm going to give it because this is a full hacking week.
Like I did, you know, nine to five, um, you know, for this week, trying to get back into
the schedule of things and stuff like that.
And then on the last day I popped like three bugs and a crit, you know, that paid out right
before this call.
So I'm very, very hyped about that.
That's awesome.
Uh, but you know, that it takes a little while to get back into your groove.
And that's one of the things that I, that I see people that are beginners.
I mean, I mean, obviously even pros struggle with it, right?
You know, cause we're having this conversation right now, but, um, this is one of the things
I see almost all hackers struggle with actually is, is this whole concept of like, okay,
how much time do I devote into this?
How do I get restarted when I'm not, you know, already in the zone?
How do I get back in that flow state?
And dude, I mean, it's, I w I'm going to like come back and listen to this next time.
I'm in this same situation.
So I can give myself a little pep talk, just start and just start doing it and start hacking
and start gaining expertise on an application and do the, the violence will come.
So now I'm back, I'm back on my groove.
And, and I think one of the things I think for me, um, one of the pros that I haven't
really talked about much on the podcast about being a full-time bug bounty hunter is that
you actually don't have to deal with this very often because you, you know, you often have
a pipeline of bugs, you're hacking on a really regular basis.
And you know, unless you're taking massive amounts of time off, you very rarely have to
like redo that whole process again.
So that's, that's something I'm really grateful for.
Yeah.
I was going to say like notes are also like one of the biggest things that you can use to
help yourself because oftentimes if you think about it, like when you're hacking nine to
five, um, like every day of the week or every day of the week, you know, you come back, you
know what you were doing yesterday.
Um, like you, it's fresh in your mind, you know, at most it's maybe 10 hours, 12 hours old.
And you know, if you come back to that, you, you know what you were working on.
But if you go away for like a week, a lot of times like your memory then gets filled
with other things that you were doing.
Like you kind of start to forget about the like recency of the specifics of the details
of things that you were looking into.
So if you take notes of those things, like everything that you're working on, like all
the things that you were looking down, all the things that you like wanted to still investigate,
and then you come back to it like that can help offset that, um, that like delay of like
not knowing where to start and what things to look at.
Cause you have a list of things that, you know, you were already looking at and you can
sort of kickstart that.
The other thing is, um, like you just have to remember that anytime you start a new program,
it's always going to be like this.
So we have the same problem when we start like any new program, there's always that discovery
period in the beginning.
And just takes time to like get familiar with the program, like spend time sussing it out,
understanding the ins and outs.
If you've taken time off and switched programs, then like that's, you know, double whammy, right?
So you have no context on this new program.
You still have to do discovery phase and you're trying to kickstart yourself with no notes,
no starting point, no nothing.
Like, yeah, it's definitely going to be a little bit of a slow roll, but once you can get there,
you know, take notes on everything that's like, looks interesting.
So that way when you come back, like even if you take two days off, you can come back again,
you have notes, stuff to look at.
Yeah, no, that that's, that's a great insight, dude.
And I actually, it's funny you mentioned that without even knowing it, because I actually
had been tuning up, you know, my notes game.
Cause we've, we talk about it on the pod a decent bit and we've seen an overwhelming
representation of the, the no notes sort of people.
Right.
Um, but ever since that happened, I was like, man, there's gotta be people that take notes
on a, you know, on a pretty regular basis.
So I've been, I've been finding them and I'm going to have them on the pod.
Um, and we're going to be able to interview them about their, their note taking things.
But, um, one of the things that I've noticed that's pretty consistent, um, across the note
takers is they are very consistent top performers on one program.
Right.
You don't see a lot of people that switch programs on a regular basis, taking very
detailed notes, but the people that do take notes, they stick to one program and they
absolutely crush it.
And they know the insides and outs of that program.
Like they are the person for that program.
Right.
Um, so that was really inspiring to me.
And, and I started to, so I'm going to look at my notes right here.
I've got a section that says almost volumes slash gadgets.
Okay.
That those are the things that are sort of like, um, uh, you know, almost there that
maybe I might be able to use in a chain.
I've got app segments, which is actually like on the target that I'm, I'm talking
about, it's one big domain, but there's lots of different like sub apps under
different paths, right.
That have different JS files are clearly different, you know, um, segments of the
app and knowing about each one of those, you know, you can try to chain together
pieces from all the different ones to, to build gadgets.
And then I've just kind of got interesting functionality and notes on the actual
deep dive and then specific target specific notes.
Um, well, and I can tell that you've already done some of that discovery phase too,
because those things that you mentioned, even, even just like that, that sub
app concept, it shows that like, yeah, you spend time looking at this, you realize
that there was some sort of a pattern here.
And eventually like you sort of cracked it in a sense that makes sense, at least
for now, like a lot of, a lot of the time, like while we're doing this stuff, I think
it's kind of like running theories where like, you don't really know a hundred
percent what's going on, but like, you can take a pretty good guess based on the
behavior that you see.
And so a lot of times it's good to make those sort of assumptions where you say,
okay, I'm pretty sure this is how this is working.
I'm going to run with this theory until I run into some data that, you know,
contradicts my, my theory.
And then I can rework my theory if I need to.
And that can let you, you know, find vulnerabilities because if you, if you have a good
idea of how it's working in the backend or like what it's actually doing, then you can,
you know, make more educated guesses towards the type of bugs that you're targeting or
the types of techniques that you're trying.
And so I, I like that sort of like running theory type stuff where basically you have,
you know, Oh, there's sub apps here.
Okay.
You know, I'm going to run with that theory until I see something that contradicts it.
Or maybe there's like two different systems here and that leads you down.
And it also helps you like identify like anomalies within those patterns.
So that if something does contradict your theory, you're like, huh, that's weird.
Like why, what is that?
Like, why does that behave differently?
Yeah, no, a hundred percent.
And the same sort of thing, you know, Franz was talking about on the episode, you know,
with him about, about mapping out what's going to be happening in your head.
And I think taking notes on that is, is a really big, yeah, it's a really big benefit.
And, and actually, so taking the notes thing a little bit further, I need to get a couple
of these people on, but one of the things that I've, I've noticed in particular that people
who really crush it on one program have been taking notes on is OAuth stuff, you know,
enumerating different client IDs, enumerating different scopes associated with different,
you know, apps, trying to get client secrets, that sort of thing.
Right.
And, and very, very cool because using those things, we can start to really map out and
really understand at a deep level and man, do they understand it at a deep level, how
the permissioning works for a given app.
And so I just started diving that a little bit deeper and I already found a crit like less
than a week in, um, with it.
Uh, and, and as I'm, as we're recording this episode, I'm seeing notifications pop on my phone.
Like, okay, yep, we're dealing with it.
We're dealing with it now.
Um, so that's, that's, that's always good to see.
Um, and so yeah, especially off base notes, I think really, really important.
Yeah.
I mean, off stuff is always like really weird.
Um, because the more complex that an organization is oftentimes there's multiple
spots where you'll log in and, uh, the, the behaviors of those off systems, either
they have to be centralized, which means that they have some sort of like a
off mechanism or like a centralized off system or they're implemented separately,
which means that there needs to be consistency across multiple implementations.
And so in both cases, there's rooms for error and there's rooms for, for holes and stuff.
So I, we actually have some, some running notes in a separate document.
So I think we'll, uh, we're going to have an OAuth episode soon.
I don't know if it'll be today though.
I don't think it's today.
Yeah.
I it's on the episode for today, dude.
We have so much stuff to cover and we're already, you know, as far in as we have,
and we haven't even covered the first bullet point.
So, um, yeah, no, we'll definitely have an episode on that.
I feel like I need to deep dive it a little bit more before we get the episode on it though.
But I will say, Joel, I don't know if you went back and listened to the SAML episode
that I released last week.
Um, I know you've been all over the place.
I think you're recording in a hotel right now, but, um, yeah, that, that, that sort of
thing, um, you know, it will also apply a lot, a lot to the, uh, OAuth and, and open ID
stuff.
Um, so definitely gonna excited to keep deep having that.
Yeah.
Um, all right, dude, we launched the discord, man.
We did launch the discord.
It's out there.
What are your thoughts?
It's been really crazy.
Um, we're up to almost a thousand members now.
I just checked this morning.
It's like, you know, almost a thousand.
Um, and, uh, yeah, it's really awesome to see just like all the people coming in, having
conversations like every day, there's just hacking conversations, just random.
Things, um, people posting research and tools and Hey, I found this thing.
Hey, anybody got an idea about this?
It's, it's, it's really awesome to see, um, the community, like, you know, communicating
and working on blocks together and just like, you know, enjoying this, this space.
So yeah, already just one weekend.
It's really an amazing or two weeks.
One week.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
I was, I was so, so excited and, uh, encouraged by how much of a response we've had from the
community and how active all the channels are.
Um, and yeah.
And also just big shout out to anyone who got in on the, the, um, subscriptions, the discord
subscription memberships early on.
Um, that is like so exciting for us to see and, uh, very exciting for our wallets as well,
because we've been running critical thinking at like what, like 500, $600 burn rate per month
ever since the beginning, pretty much.
So, um, getting some, some income to offset that is really, really helpful for it.
So for those of you that want to support the pod, definitely go check out the discord subs.
Um, and we're dropping a bunch of really cool stuff in the, uh, exclusive subscribers channel,
uh, mostly in the, in the, uh, the critical thinkers, critical thinkers channel.
Um, definitely.
Like it's not just like for supporting the pod.
Like obviously we appreciate the support, but it's also for you guys.
Um, you know, it's really for sharing exclusive information and stuff.
We posted a bunch of different, um, exclusive techniques and tips and links and tools and
all sorts of things in the, in the critical thinkers chat.
Um, we're working on setting up our first masterclass.
You've got some AMA questions coming in.
So yeah, there's a lot of really awesome, awesome things that are available in those,
in the paid tiers that are more exclusive benefits.
Um, but just in general, like there's tons of people who just come in chatting the general
chat, hacking the hacking chat.
It's really, it's really awesome.
Yeah.
I mean, we've definitely had some more, I think the discussions that happen in the, the
supporter chats, you know, they're, they're, uh, a lot of them are tailored to specific
vulnerabilities and stuff you want to keep in the, you know, more exclusive channels.
But there's been a lot of great, um, high quality stuff, like you mentioned in the general
and hacking channels as well.
And, uh, so I just grabbed a couple of the things that I wanted to kind of just give you
guys a taste of what we're seeing in the discord.
Um, the first thing was we're seeing a lot of conversation and really helpful conversation,
actually surrounding JS monitoring.
Um, and, and I'm a little, I'm not gonna lie to Joel.
I'm a little, like a little sad actually to see so many people do this because like,
I feel like, you know, content creation in the bug bounty realm is a little bit tricky,
uh, because it's like, okay, you know, do what do I share and how much do I share?
Right.
And then when I share how much competition am I creating for myself?
And I will say, I have noticed an increase in dupes since we started doing critical thinking.
I ha I really have.
That's interesting.
Um, and, and stuff that you wouldn't really think is a dupe either.
And, and, you know, it could just be my, my, you know, bias or whatever.
But, um, uh, you know, I guess it, it, it, there, when there are people actually taking
the advice, it's, it's a little bit, you know, and people talking about it in the chat,
like, oh, you know, I set up this script, um, you know, I'm, I'm monitoring this endpoint
and I already found these bugs.
I'm like, all right, well, there goes one of my, you know, it's true because like literally
just the other day, somebody in the, in the critical thinkers chat, they pinged us and
they were like, yeah, you know, like I was stuck on this bug and like, then I was listening
to the episode and you guys mentioned this thing and I tried it and it worked and like,
you know, I wouldn't have even thought about that.
I was like, oh man, like, uh, yeah.
I mean, and it's great.
It's great to see, but also, you know, it, it does, it's that, it's that dichotomy, you
know, it's that, it's that battle, uh, that you have as a kind of creator in bug bounty,
but needless to say, we're glad to see it.
We're going to keep them coming for y'all.
Um, because you know, when the community continues to perform bug bounty industry continues to perform
and you know, a rising tide lifts all boats.
Is that it?
That is the saying.
Yeah.
That is the expression, man.
I got it.
Um, there's a mentality, there's a whole like psych psychology thing behind this between like,
um, yeah, uh, there's like two mentalities where it's like finite mentality and like,
I don't know what the other one is, but it's basically like, is it one piece?
Infinite game mentality.
Is that the Simon Sinek thing?
Yeah.
It's one pie.
It, when somebody gets added, is it, does everybody get a smaller slice of the pie or
does the pie increase?
Um, and like, usually like people individually, like have like a sort of, sort of a set like
view on this, um, about like how they think about things just in general.
And it's like the same thing with bug bounty where it's like, you know, if I share data,
like, am I taking away from my bounties or am I just like increasing the overall research
and then everybody gets more bounties, et cetera.
Yeah.
And to be honest, man, everyone's got such a unique perspective when it comes to what kind of
bugs they're going to find as well.
It's very unlikely that, that I am actually causing dupes for myself, but I will, you
know, I, I think we mentioned the one time when we had Alex Chapman on the pod, there was
one, one occasion when, uh, a blog that Alex wrote really helped me in exploiting a bug
that he duped on.
Uh, and, and I, that just, uh, in that moment, I was like, man, I feel for you, brother.
That's so funny.
Yeah.
Um, the things I wanted to shout out in particular were a couple of the people on the discord,
um, XNL hacker who you guys probably know, we've shouted him out lots, um, for the tools
he's making is, um, is using a modified version of a tool called JS mon, um, which is a, uh,
it may exactly what it sounds like.
It's sort of JavaScript change monitor for bug bounty.
Um, we got another person in there, uh, Abby, who's using a custom script, uh, and using the
scrappy, uh, Python library to reach out and do the JavaScript monitoring, which is actually
very close to what I do.
And he writes a custom script for each individual, um, uh, company that he's monitoring, you know,
tailored to that company's JS files and, you know, running regexes that will produce results
on that company's JS files.
And then, um, there's a couple other people.
I don't, I'm not even going to try to pronounce E E Tiamis.
Uh, and then static flow as well is also might be building something for the people.
I don't know.
I don't know if static flow is ready to, uh, you know, announce that yet, but we've been
having some, uh, exciting chats on a secret channel in the discord.
So, uh, Tanner, whenever you're ready to drop that thing, man, you know, the world might
be ready for it.
So, yeah, absolutely.
No, we've been, um, we've been working behind the scenes with Tanner on, uh, static
flow on some, uh, some cool stuff.
So we're hoping again, more, some exclusive stuff.
So if you're interested, you know, go check out the discord, but, um, yeah, we're, we're
hoping to have some more exclusive critical thinking tooling and, uh, all sorts of fun
things coming out very soon.
Yeah, dude, this, the, the swag game should be fun too.
Coming up.
We're, we're working on that.
I don't know what the timeline, like, is that going to be?
Because I was like, I was, yeah, I was talking to our, our person who's kind of helping with
that.
And I was like, Hey, you know, you think we could roll this out by Christmas?
And they're like, no.
It's like late November.
It's like, yeah, can we do this in a month during the busiest season?
Not a chance.
So yeah, no, that makes sense.
Um, yeah.
Okay.
So obviously, uh, just a couple, a couple more things mentioned in the discord was, uh,
secondary context bugs, which we've talked about on the pod a decent bit.
I'll mostly skip over this now, but I, I am glad to see people saying, Hey, I'm actually
finding secondary context bugs out here that have high impact.
Um, and, and actually I know of a couple of people that haven't even posted in the discord
publicly, but I've DMed me privately saying, Hey, found some cool secondary context bugs and
scored massive, massive bounties from it.
Yeah.
Secondary context bugs are really, really interesting.
We talked about it a bunch.
So if you're interested, you can check out, um, a good example, Sam Curry's, uh, Starbucks,
uh, Sam Curry and Ryan or reader featuring Ryan or reader.
Yeah.
Oh, that guy.
Who's that?
What the heck man?
I mean, it's not Sam Curry.net.
I don't know what to tell you.
It's dude.
Well, it's Sam Curry shit.
You know, it really is.
There's, there's a specific brand of stuff and that's Sam Curry shit right there.
Um, but yeah, sorry, I need to get some water.
But the, uh, the last thing was like, there's been some really good automationist, you know,
the automation is shit.
Yeah.
In, um, in the discord, we've talked a good bit about, um, DNS wildcard filter and I'll
just kind of give the TLDR of that here.
Um, a lot of people have a lot of different approaches.
Some tools do it automatically.
I think DNSX does some stuff.
Um, but really it's kind of a hard problem to nail down.
And one of the approaches that seems to have worked best for me, and I've kind of
discussed a little bit with the community is this concept of wildcard profiles.
Um, and, um, what you'll do is when you, when you detect a wildcard, um, when you're doing
subdomain enumeration, um, you, you will take that wildcard and put it through a process
to create a profile for what this specific wildcard looks like.
So you're generating multiple, um, iterations.
You're resolving it multiple times.
You're querying different resolvers.
You're adding and prepending things, you know, trying to figure out exactly where the, uh,
wildcard break is, um, in the, in the, uh, definition, uh, you know, where it is at,
uh, in the subdomain structure, that sort of thing.
And then you're also resolving it multiple times with multiple resolvers to try to get,
um, an idea of what IPs are being round Robin returned in that, in that, and then creating
a profile of sorts, uh, for what that wildcard should look like.
And then when you resolve things, which match that wildcard, um, in the subdomain level,
but do not match that response, then, you know, you've got a diamond in the rough, something
that most people, other people won't find because they're just going to be saying, all right,
everything under dot, whatever is, is a, is a wildcard.
Um, and I'm just going to ignore it, but this one isn't.
And so, um, there's a lot of really good scope living in those sort of, uh, and those
sort of caveats, if you can read between the lines for the DNS.
Yeah, for sure.
And, um, an interesting thing about wildcards.
So I'm pretty sure this is like all the time.
Um, but basically like the way that you can figure a wildcard on DNS is that your, your
a record, essentially the, the, the record itself is, is an asterisk.
It's a star.
Mm-hmm .
Yeah.
So you can, you can do a lookup on that.
If you think something's a wildcard and you want to verify, you can actually just dig
star dot, whatever.com.
No, you cannot.
Yes, you can.
Yep.
And it actually, yeah, yeah, totally.
What the frick, Joel?
Yeah.
Hold up.
No.
Hold on.
Just a second.
I gotta, I gotta.
What?
Well, I mean, okay.
I guess that sort of makes sense because it anything there, I mean, what can I do?
A slash there?
Like, oh yeah.
Okay.
But any character is gonna return that though.
Right?
Right.
But typically like a DNS, right?
Like, because that's the way that it's being configured.
Like, yes, the wildcard is probably wildcarding itself maybe, but.
Yeah.
That's also a really easy way that you can concretely check.
Interesting.
If you're not sure that something is a wildcard.
I wonder if some authoritative name servers will actually result, like give you more information
if you actually hit star.whatever.com rather than, you know, blahdyblah.whatever.com.
That's very interesting.
I didn't know that.
It's super interesting behavior.
Sure.
Yeah.
Because like I can, I have some wildcards configured on my own domain and I do, it's configured
like that.
Like you do an asterisk.whatever.
And you can, you know, look it up.
And I'm not sure if it's that the wildcard is wildcarding itself or if that's just that,
you know, it's wildcarding everything else and it's giving you the literal lookup.
But either way, like that's a really good way that you can get basically the wildcard
response and then you can use that to filter it.
So if you're not sure that something's a wildcard, you can literally just start up.
Yeah.
Very nice, dude.
I didn't know that.
That's definitely something to keep in mind.
And, you know, we've been kind of scheming with some of the guys in there with Golden
and them, you know, about how exactly to get this stuff to work.
And you have to put together so many different pieces of the puzzle when trying to do this
effectively.
And we've been seeing some experts hop in there like Sean, S-Y, will hop in there.
Yeah.
From AssetNote.
And give some good stuff.
So I really appreciate the guests also being active in the Discord.
That's really encouraging to see.
Yeah.
It was hilarious.
On the first day, he was like, what's happening?
I just woke up and my phone is exploding.
I have like a million notifications from this Discord.
I'm asleep.
There was 15 people in here.
I woke up.
There's 500 people in here.
Yeah, dude.
We probably should have let them know.
But we had all the guests join the Discord in advance because we were using it for like
logistics stuff with planning and that sort of thing.
And then, you know, we didn't really tell anyone we were going to launch it.
And then all of a sudden, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
You know, like the welcome channel is like blowing up.
So if you're listening, sorry about that, Sean.
Hope you get some sleep.
Sorry for anyone on the Asia time zone when we launched that.
But yeah.
Cool.
There was another tool that I saw posted in there.
It's called Thank You Next.
Yeah.
And this seems specifically for Next.js.
So I believe Next.js is mostly used for Web3 applications.
But it might be used for other things.
But it's called Thank You Next.
Letter U.
Like Thank You Next.js.
Basically, all it does is it just parses.
It looks for a Next.js build manifest.
And then it will parse out all of the routes that are available through that, through the
Next.js build manifest.
And it will just print them out for you.
Super easy.
So if you're looking at Next.js applications, you see it's using Next.js.
You can just run it through this tool.
It'll give you all the routes.
Super easy, nice, cool piece of research.
Dude.
I love this.
I really, I love this a lot.
And actually, this is something very sort of related to something that I wanted to talk
about on the pod today, which was this concept of client-side paths.
And when we think about JS, when we think about JS file recon, you know, reading the JS files,
trying to extract the endpoints, that sort of thing, we kind of think about this, like, you know,
grit your teeth process of staring at the JS and, like, till your eyes bleed and, like, trying to trace back all these functions to, like, you know, get the correct parameters for a request that's going to be sent to the server-side API.
But in reality, something that I've been sleeping on is this whole concept of looking at how the client-side routing actually works.
Because, like, nine times out of ten, the applications that you're dealing with nowadays are going to all return the same, you know, you're going to hit slash blah-de-blah,
and it's still going to return the same response.
And then the JS on the client-side, you know, Angular, React, Next.js, or whatever, is going to look at the path and show you a page based off of that, right?
Right.
And so looking at these client-side paths as well within the JS files is massively helpful.
Because not only can you trigger, you know, various functions that are bound to these routes and maybe even get XSS.
I've popped several XSS over the past week because of this trick.
But you can also not have to, like, go through this terrible process of trying to figure out, like, you know, what parameters go where in a request.
And actually just have the app generated for you by forcing a specific state in the application by navigating to that route.
And I just, I don't know why I haven't been doing this more often.
And it's just, it's a great trick.
Well, and another thing that I've noticed is that, especially with Webpack stuff, so a lot of times you'll still have the Webpack map files.
And you can unmap it.
You can view it in your browser.
Or you can unmap it locally.
And oftentimes what you'll see is that the pages, there's usually a folder called, like, pages.
And it has, like, the JSX or whatever.
Is that the right terminology?
The, like, JS templating thing?
No, no, no.
Like, like the .tsx files.
Tssx.
Like, for TypeScripts.
And then JSX, I think, probably for just straight JavaScript stuff.
Yeah.
Right, right.
So basically those, like, HTML-esque JavaScript templating type of stuff that's used in React, typically.
Yeah.
And you'll see that it'll only return, like, one page.
And a lot of the time that's because it's using either lazy loaded JavaScript.
Or because it's explicitly, like, checking whether or not it should load other parts of the app.
Even though it's in the code, you just have to do a little bit more digging.
And the page, like, IDs and stuff are in there.
So just, like, what you're talking about where essentially, like, all this stuff is on the client side already.
Like, the front-end pages, like, there might be back-end API endpoints that it's hitting.
And those will also be in the JavaScript.
But really, the available pages for you to browse are all within that file right there.
And so you can look through and you can find them and you can pull them out.
And then usually you can also go one step further and you can either get the lazy loaded file for that page.
Or you can find maybe there's a specific JS file just loaded on that page.
And that has extra functions, extra API endpoints.
All that kind of, you know, juicy, juicy info.
And a lot of times at first glance you wouldn't really see it because you might see the pages folder
and see, like, you know, two things in there and nothing's there that you haven't already seen.
But if you, you know, go just one step further.
Yeah, 100%.
And I think JS Weasel is doing a lot of this stuff, right?
Like, doing the lazy loading, you know, unpack.
It's an expensive tool.
But I have seen a couple people give testimonials recently saying, like, hey, this is really worth it.
Finding a lot more bugs with this.
And I like it.
And it's on my to-do list for this week to go and try it again.
And work on it a little bit.
And, you know, see if I can integrate it into my workflow a little bit more effectively.
Yeah.
One problem with that is it doesn't have Kaido integration.
And Kaido is my main tool that I'm using now for proxying.
I switched over a couple weeks back.
And I've put probably 80 to 120 hours in Kaido over the past three or four weeks.
Dude, I gotta say, I love everything about Kaido except for there's one thing.
And this has always irked me.
And it's the scope control.
Like, the way that they handle scopes is, like, it has to be basically, like, you have to know what the domain is.
Like, the root domain.
In some extent.
Yeah.
Because, like, on Burp, you can literally just put, like, Word.
And it'll just regex.
And I love that.
I literally, there's an open ticket.
They're going to push it in, I think, probably the next patch or maybe the patch after that.
But I've told them, like, dude, 90% of the time, I just want to give it a keyword.
And I want to see, you know, S3 buckets that have Facebook in it.
I want to see, you know, tangential domains that have, you know, the word Facebook in it or whatever.
Like, that's the way to do it.
And it'll get there.
It'll get there.
And in the meantime, it's a little bit of a pain.
Yeah, because I found, like, for example, I've also been trying to use Kaido significantly more as, like, my main tool.
Mainly just because the projects, like, honestly, like, I wish it was more than this.
But the project switching is just, like, a huge hassle in Burp.
And the fact that you can just, like, make a new project and you can just switch through it in the same window and all that.
It's so nice.
It's, like, a two-minute time.
Like, I have, like, a crazy, crazy strong server that I use as my main, you know, computer here.
128 gigs of RAM, top processor I could get at the time.
It still takes me, like, two minutes to switch into Burp projects, right?
Yeah.
And kind of, it's literally three seconds.
I used to do this, like, really janky setup where I would run multiple instances of Burp because it's got so much.
It's gone on my nerves so badly that I would run multiple instances of Burp and I would only, like, I would have the proxy tab open.
And I would just uncheck the listener on the other instances that I wasn't using.
And then when I'd switch projects, I would, like, uncheck, minimize, bring up the other instance, turn the proxy on, and just, like, do it like that.
And just ignore all the warnings and whatever when you launch with the temporary files.
And, like, it's just a pain.
So I've been switching more to Kaido.
And that's, like, the one thing that really that I miss is that I was hacking on a scope, for example, and I had their domain in there.
And usually what I'll do is I'll do percent.domain.com as well as domain.com because that's another thing that, like, you have to explicitly, anyways.
And I was, like, doing a bunch of hunting.
And sure enough, I see in the DNS logs, like, there's some completely separate root domain that, like, had the keyword in it.
But I didn't know it existed.
And I was like, oh, shit.
Like, maybe I've been, you know, who knows?
Maybe I've been missing stuff on this.
So, you know, once they get that added, that'll be really awesome.
I do like the idea of the, like, the scope control that they have.
But I think for bug bounty hunting, often it needs to be, like, just very broad and generic.
Or just do a full regex.
Yeah, exactly.
Just make it regex.
We can all write regex, you know?
Default to regex, please.
Yeah.
If you can't write regex, you need to go fix that.
You know, like, there's so many bugs that happen because of regex.
Hackers, 90% of the time, should be able to write regex.
All right.
Crazy side tangent here.
Oh, jeez.
When I first started hacking, I used to write in Burp full regex statements with, like, conditional oars and, like, every subdomain, everything in one entry in my host, in my, like, target config in Burp.
And one time I was at a live hacking event and Chubbs saw me doing that and he was like, what are you doing?
And I was like, I was like, I'm adding this to the scope.
He was like, dude, just put, like, what, just put, like, Facebook.
I was like, we've always had, we've all had that moment with Chubbs.
Anyone who's met Chubbs has been, and, you know, he's kind as can be that.
He's like, hey, man, I just want to let you know.
He, like, called Naffy over.
He's like, Naffy.
I was like, he's like, dude, can you, this guy's writing full regexes for all his hosts.
I was like, doesn't everybody do this?
No, no, Joel.
But from that day, I realized the easiest way is just keyword.
And yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
Same sort of thing with when I first learned that you could rename tabs.
Oh, by the way, on that note, you know, another thing about Kaido is that I've really been, okay, here we go.
We're going on a tangent here.
Let's just do it.
Back, I'm going on a tangent.
Let's do it, though.
It's that kind of day on the pod.
So going back to what we were talking about before with notes, I've had the opportunity to screen share with some hackers that I really respect recently and that take very deep notes.
And these hackers that I'm talking about, they're not using Burp or Kaido or Zap.
They're using Postman.
And it's because they're coming from a dev background, right?
Okay.
And it works for them.
Postman keeps your histories, right?
Yeah.
And they're using, like, they're using, what are they using?
It's, like, Fiddler, maybe, I think, to get, like, as a proxy.
And then they'll recreate it in Postman.
And I was like, okay, that's ridiculous.
Why would you do that?
You know, it takes so much time.
But here's the thing, man.
The guy that I'm thinking of has, like, a whole collection of, like, essentially built out API docs for his target
with sample requests and he knows everything about it.
And he's a master of it, you know?
Like, and it's all organized.
You know, all the tabs have, like, get, you know, and then whatever path you're doing, it's very easy to navigate through and get the request you need.
And so big, big fan of that.
I definitely don't think that you need to go as far as to use Postman with it.
But I've mentioned to Kaido, like, hey, it would be really cool if we could provide some sort of, like, either even, like, an LLM prompt or, like, some sort of configuration to auto-name our tabs.
And, you know, have them put into a certain collection or something like that based off of where they are in the application and that sort of thing.
And just get a little bit more organized and be able to use the collections a little better.
And I'm actually getting to the point now where I am using the collections better in Kaido, where I'm creating, you know, certain collections for gadgets, for volms, for interesting requests I need to come back to, for specific chains that I'll need to do.
Like, oh, I'm going to chain this request and this request and this request together in that order.
So then I just create a collection, drop them all in there, boom, boom, boom, that sort of thing.
So definitely some value in being a little bit more organized with your collections, which I'm really appreciative that Kaido has in place.
Yeah, for sure.
So I used to do a very similar thing.
I don't use Postman.
I like Postman, but I use a tool called Paw.
Or, well, what's it called now?
Rapid API.
Paw.Cloud.
But it's Mac only.
So maybe that's why Postman.
But it's basically the same thing.
You know, it lets you structure, you know, sort of like a developer, really.
Like, you can group your requests.
You can set up different HTTP requests.
They all have, like, parameterized inputs.
You know, it's made for, like, testing APIs, really.
Yeah.
As a developer.
But the really nice use case that I like to use it for is when I have very complex HTTP requests that often require some sort of crypto.
Good example of this is OAuth HMAC.
I believe Twitter uses this.
I think there's a couple other things that use it that I'm blanking on.
But sometimes they will use OAuth HMAC in their authentication flow.
And it requires that you have to generate a signature for every single request.
And that it has to, like, have a token that's, like, based on your current request and has to be included in the request.
And it's, like, you can't do it in BERT, like, in any easy way whatsoever.
That would be the worst.
It's in Python.
But these tools often have extensions that are designed exactly for this.
So you say, oh, my auth is OAuth.
Here's my key.
Here's my secret.
Done.
That's it.
Like, you just send your request.
It automatically signs it.
It automatically puts the token in.
It automatically does all that kind of stuff.
And in addition to that, because it's designed for APIs, you can often structure it.
So, for example, you can use variables.
I assume you can probably do this in Postman.
I'm not 100% familiar.
But you can in Rapid API where you say, you know, within this project, I have a variable called, let's say, hostname.
Right?
And then all of your requests, you just reference the variable hostname.
And then if you need to change that or you want to have maybe a staging environment that you want to test instead, you just change it in one place, it changes it everywhere.
And so there's some really nice things that you can do with the sort of, like, structured side of that, the, like, developer side of those testing tools that make it really nice to test APIs.
Honestly, the only hassle with it is that you have to kind of, like, rewrite it.
Right?
So, like, it's not as easy as just sending it to your repeater tab and just, like, editing the path and sending it.
You have to basically, like, clone it in.
There are importers, I think, in most of these tools.
So, like, you can paste it from, like, curl or you can paste it from a raw HTTP request and it'll, like, parse it out.
But, you know, it's a little bit of a hassle.
But, again, for those cases where it's, like, you know, signing or HMAC and that kind of stuff, it's really, really good for those.
That would be huge in Burp or Kaido, having the ability to set a variable and say, like, okay, this is going to be my org ID always, you know?
And just be able to reference that in all of the requests and then have it replace it.
Like, it's almost Hackverter-esque, right?
Where, like, it's kind of, it's, like, Hackverter as a whole application where, like, it's really designed around, like, you can have gadgets.
You can, like, in Paa, for example, like, you can wrap variables in different functions and gadgets that, like, modify that.
So, you can, like, hex encode or you can, you know, basic decode or decode.
Like, you can do all sorts of different modifications on stuff, like, on the fly.
That makes it really, you know, really useful for those things.
Things that you could probably do to some extent with Hackverter.
But without an extension, there's just no way to do it in Burp.
Yeah.
And in Kaido, you can do it with convert workflows.
If you just select the whole request and then send it to a convert workflow, you know, shell out and then do it in Python and then replace it back or whatever, you could definitely make that work.
So, that's interesting.
Once Kaido actually implements the whole keep your workflows across multiple projects thing, I think I'm going to do that because that's the other big pain point right now is that I have to redefine my convert.
stuff for every single project.
But once they do that, I think I'll start doing a little bit more tooling surrounding that sort of thing.
That would definitely be huge.
And I would love to see that it also integrated with a built-in sort of request minimizer like they have in Burp.
It's a Burp extension.
But something that just breaks the request down to the bare bones, you know?
Okay, I know I need this cookie.
I wanted to like it so bad, but it never works for me.
What?
It always works for me.
What do you mean it doesn't work for you?
Whenever I use it, it always like gives me like it takes a long time and then it gives me like a weird output that like doesn't that doesn't work.
And so, I end up just doing it myself.
Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe I'm doing it wrong.
But yeah.
It definitely takes a long time.
I'll give you that.
And there's no feedback because of how Burp plugins are designed, you know?
But it always gives me a good result.
And yeah, I guess you need to make sure you're giving it the base request, right?
With the expected output as the response.
Because the first thing it's going to do is it's going to send the request with the output.
And then it's going to remove everything that still results in anything different than that output, right?
And so, yeah, that's a cool tool.
I would love to see that integrated into Kaido as well.
Really looking forward to when we get to plugins and I'm able to just sit down and like, you know, code out all these plugins that I need.
This is our chance, Justin.
We could be ahead of the market.
All they have to do is monetize plugins and we're billionaires.
Oh, true, man.
True.
Yeah.
How the heck are we going to do that?
Hackers are going to be like, just go into the code and be like, okay.
Like, is licensed, replace function.
Return true.
You know, like, it's going to be terrible.
One thing I did want to mention before we get too lost on this tangent.
Charlie from JS Weasel is in the Discord.
Yeah.
And he's posted a couple of really useful like tips, feature updates, things that people didn't really know.
I saw he posted something about being able to combine the files that it found.
Yeah.
Everybody was like, wait, what?
You could do that?
I didn't know that was a thing.
That's super cool.
So don't go in there and pester him about problems.
He said, I think he even dropped an email that, like, I think it's support at JSWeasel.io, I want to say.
Yeah.
But, you know, if you have like problems, just like send an email because that's the best way for them to track it.
But he's posting really awesome stuff in there.
You know, he's letting people know about really cool things.
So it's an awesome way to interact with Charlie from JS Weasel.
Yeah.
If that's something you're interested in.
I know the Kaido guys as well are in there.
And they also have their own Discord, which is super like, you know, great place to, they're very responsive in there.
If you file support tickets, it's all like, you know, they make it super easy.
So, yeah, you should check out their Discord too, the Kaido Discord.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I've been pleased with, like I mentioned, XNLHacker is in there.
Bebex is in there.
Speaking of Bebex.
Dude, awesome tool that will.
Yeah.
There was so many cool researches.
It's down a little bit in the notes.
I don't remember, to be honest, he released it quite a while ago, but I don't think we've talked about it yet because we had a couple episodes queued to get us through the holidays.
But he released this SSRF.CVSSAdvisor.com thing.
And I saw it before.
And if I shouted it out, you know, it was in passing.
I've used this extensively now.
And it rocks.
This is a great collaborator.
Replacement for collaborator.
Yeah.
I was going to say, more and more, dude.
I run into the problem where my Burp Collab is blocked because I just used the default one.
And, like, it's such a hassle to set up your own Burp Collab server.
Like, unless you do it in the cloud where there's no IP restrictions.
And, like, even then, like, you often want a domain.
Like, it's a whole thing.
And, like, why is this so hard?
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
It's a real pin.
A hundred percent.
And this solves a lot of it.
And I kind of talked about this before.
Actually, I think I sent out a tweet about it, which is, like, for any people building Burp plugins right now, like, stop.
And make it something a little bit more generic.
Make it something that can be used, you know, in Kaido.
Something that can be used in Burp.
Something that can be used in Postman or whatever.
Right?
I really like the trend of having this, you know, go in a different direction.
That's why I really appreciate what Bebex did there.
And it's got more features.
And it's a you can define your response and that sort of thing, which is really cool.
One of the things that just came to mind because of what you just said is I wonder if you would be open to coding it in such a way that you can define your own domain and then just point it at it.
Point it at the IP address.
Right?
Yeah.
I just don't know how it does the, like, the routing.
Maybe it's all Vhost or something.
Yeah.
But it seems pretty doable, right?
This kind of reminds me of, like, way back when Bug Bounty first started popping off in, like, 2017, 2018.
There was a big influx of tool development where, like, Durbuster, GoSearch, Durb, Fuff, like, you know, all these, like, crazy, crazy tools just, like, popped out of the woodworks, like, got created out of necessity.
And then things kind of died down.
A lot of stuff got consolidated into, like, the proxy tools or whatever.
But now we're seeing, like, we're kind of returning back to fundamentals.
And it's nice to see that, like, the community is sort of, like, surging back and being like, hey, you know, like, you could probably do this with Burp Collaborator.
But if you want to do it not with Burp Collaborator because of need I go back into all the problems that people have with Burp Collaborator, you know, you can do this.
And it reminds me, like, back in the day, there was a lot of tools that were, like, this ping bin, HTTP bin.
Yeah.
There was a couple other ones.
Yeah, DNS bin.
Like, there were always, like, separate tools for, like, the different protocols and stuff that were all just, like, online tools.
You just, like, open it up.
It would give you a random URL.
And you could just use it as your payload.
It's pretty functional, you know?
Yeah.
But a lot of them are, like, dead now, unfortunately.
So it's nice that, like, we're kind of reviving it to some extent.
I don't know if this SRF testing tool is only for HTTP and HTTPS.
Yeah, it is.
And I'm not even sure it's for, I haven't used it for HTTP yet.
So I'm not even sure that it supports HTTP.
But I'm really excited about the fact that I need to hit Pevix up after this pod and tell him, hey, man, it would be great if you could just, like, provide, we could provide our own domain pointing at that IP address and have your own version without any setup necessary, right?
That should be totally doable.
And then the other thing is, like, I would love, the one thing that this does or doesn't do that Collaborator does do, couldn't get that out, is that it doesn't do DNS, right?
And DNS is huge.
And it's a pain in the butt to, you know, get it set up sometimes, you know?
I've talked before about how easy it is to get it set up with DNS Chef, but it's not as simple as HTTP for sure.
But I would love to see that also sort of integrated into this.
I could definitely see the community really starting to get behind this project as a primary replacement to Collaborator if we could define our own domains and then also get DNS callbacks.
That would be huge.
Yeah.
I mean, this is basically, like, all those tools that I was talking about earlier, like, all those HTTP-based ping bin, DNS bin, HTTP bin, whatever bin, all in, you know?
But, well, this is really just HTTP right now.
But hopefully we can, you know, get to that, all those other protocols and everything, too.
And then maybe provide it in a way that other people can mess with it, too.
Yeah.
100%.
Dude, we are not even halfway done with the pre-episode.
So we're not going to get to the full episode today.
All right.
Do you have time?
I have a little bit of time.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to keep going down talking about this cool stuff, though.
One thing that I wanted to share that we mentioned on the Discord and I realized wasn't really sort of common knowledge for people is this sort of concept of an iframe sandwich.
And it's not really an iframe sandwich, but it's sort of like an open iframe sandwich.
Okay.
And so this is something that you can do because I've mentioned before on the pod and other mediums that if you have a target that iframe's in a subdomain.
So let's say the first time I actually fully exploited this, the scenario was my target domain, iframe in a marketing subdomain where you could control your email preferences or whatever.
Right?
Okay.
Not a huge impact in that scenario, but I did something cool with it with OAuth stuff and got ATO.
No big deal.
Yeah.
But in that scenario, the iframe domain, which is a different domain from the primary domain, if you can pop an XSS on that iframe domain, you can do some cool shit.
Okay.
So what you can do is from an attacker and keep in mind, this domain is iframed.
So normally it has, you know, iframe allow configurations.
So what you can do from your attacker controlled page, you can iframe in and do an invisible iframe to that subdomain where you have the XSS.
Pop the XSS, get JS control.
Okay.
Then from the attacker controlled page, pop open a new tab to the victim domain that you would like to attack.
And that victim domain has the XSS vulnerable subdomain iframe in.
Right?
And then what you can do is you can reach from the iframe on the attacker controlled page up to the attacker page over to the victim domain and then down into the XSS domain on that page by using different frames.
And because you control JS on the iframe on your page, you can modify the content of the iframe on the victim domains page.
Right?
That's iframe into the victim domains page.
And you can affect that content.
So let's say in that scenario, you can rewrite the content with like, you know, something that might could leak tokens, something that could, you know, you could put even a, you know, sort of a phishing thing in there.
And that sort of thing is normally accepted in my experience because you're affecting the integrity of the in-scope application by modifying the contents of a domain that they are iframeing into their website.
And so I kind of call this an iframe sandwich.
It's not really, you know, when iframes used to be a little bit more permissive, you could do some cooler stuff with that.
But just making sure you understand how frames work and what kind of stuff you can access using parent, using opener, using the frames array.
I'm just making sure I understand this.
Yeah.
On, let's say, victim.com.
You have one taboo.
Victim.com.
Right.
Inside it, they have vulnerable.com.
Yes.
Vulnerable.com.
Yeah.
Vulnerable.com or, you know, vulnerable.victim.com or something like that.
Okay.
Sure.
And vulnerable.victim.com is vulnerable to an XSS.
Yes.
So now you get an XSS.
You have an XSS inside an iframe on victim.com.
Well, not exactly.
Okay.
So let me break it down a little bit better.
You've got two frames or two pages, two tabs with iframes in them.
Okay.
One is an attacker control or an attacker page and one of them is the victim page.
Both of them have an iframe to XSS vulnerable domain, right?
Okay.
Using the X, you can't control the path that is iframed into the victim's domain.
Yeah.
So that's always going to be iframed to wherever the victim says it should go, right?
Okay.
But on the attacker controlled page, you can control it.
So you pop XSS through that, reach back up through the attacker controlled page,
reach over to the tab that's opened up the other iframed page, reach into the iframe and
modify the content.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's almost backwards instead.
Like you're modifying the victim page from the attacker page.
Exactly.
Because it's the same iframe in both of them.
Because it's the same origin.
Yeah.
Right.
Same origin.
So you can communicate with iframes of the same origin in a different tab.
Is there a better way to explain this?
Because I had the same trouble.
You explained it from the other way around.
It was a little confusing because it was kind of like you get an XSS within this iframe
and then you set up your own page.
Like I think the way you just described it now is better where basically you have two pages.
They both iframe the same URL.
You have an XSS in both of them, but you can easily pop it from your attacker page,
which then you can use that context to communicate with the context.
They both iframe the same domain, but probably a different URL if it's a reflected XSS.
Yeah.
There's no saying that maybe on victim.com that you'd be able to actually pop it through
the URL or something.
Maybe it's a complex attack scenario.
It doesn't really matter because all you need is control over that iframe context with the
same origin.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And as long as you control, you're running JS execution on that origin and you have a path
path to reach the other frame, right?
In this scenario, it would be parent name of the other tab.
The name of the other tab.
Iframe.
Is that why you open it from victim.com?
Why you have to open it from victim.com?
No, no, no.
Well, you have attacker controlled page with the XSS embedded into it.
Oh, would you just open the victim page from your attacker page?
Exactly.
Got it.
That one.
Understood.
Yeah.
And then you hop over there and modify it.
Man, maybe I should, maybe, let me make a note here.
We need a cardboard box diagram from...
I'll draw a little, draw a diagram for iframe sandwich.
I'll draw a little diagram and put it on the screen for those of you watching on YouTube.
So basically you open attacker.com, attacker.com opens a new tab with victim.com.
They both iframe the same URL.
You pop the XSS from your attacker.com in the iframe, which can then communicate with
the iframe in the other tab on victim.com.
And then you can either control the content, you can do whatever you want within that iframe.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And, you know, depending on the refer policy and stuff like that, you might be able to
leak, you know, OAuth parameters and that sort of thing.
So all sorts of cool stuff you can do with that.
It's a good way to take an XSS in a subdomain that's, you know, maybe not even in scope or
less important and make it affect the primary domain and increase your impact.
Mm-hmm.
So these are the kind of things we're discussing in the CTPB podcast Discord.
So check it out, ctpb.show slash Discord.
Hop on in and join that conversation.
All right.
So now we're done with the pre-show and now we're in.
And now we can go into the news section.
So let's go ahead and let's pop open these links and we'll start.
We already covered Bevic's, his little, his thing on the SSRF tool.
So that's good.
We got some work done.
First thing on the list, Johan Carlson sort of retweeted a tweet that you guys really liked
from the Critical Thinking account talking about a good open redirect sort of bypass to
get open redirect.
And he added a really insightful piece of information.
Let me read that for you.
There are some good and common ways to gain redirects like at and dot.
But I have also had a lot of success with double slash.
So slash slash.
A lot of simple filters check if the URL is relative by checking if it starts with a slash,
forgetting that slash slash attacker.com is not a relative domain, but is actually an absolute URL.
And then he posts some examples down in the bottom of sort of deviations on this attack that have,
that use backslashes, that use white space, that sort of thing.
And just really good to be aware of these because sometimes if you can bypass, you know,
people make fun of open redirect as a vulnerability, but sometimes if you can bypass redirect logic,
it's a real problem.
So knowing these tricks is really helpful.
So SSRF 101 is like, yeah, yeah.
Like check if it's in the same domain.
Okay.
Well, if you have an open redirect and a lot of times it follows redirects, then game over.
Yeah.
And not even just SSRF, but also it's OAuth 101.
OAuth, yeah.
Is like, you know, if you can affect that redirect URI.
Yeah.
In some scenarios, SAML as well.
If you can affect that redirect URI, then you're golden.
So definitely, definitely something to keep in mind.
Appreciate Johan hopping in there, joining the conversation and adding something really relevant there
that I've used a ton of times and just forgot to include in that tweet.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah, the double slash thing is a classic.
I mean, you see this a lot in browsers legitimately too.
Like script URLs often use double slash.
Because I think double slash is used to default to the same protocol that the page uses, right?
Exactly.
Right.
Yep.
So if it's using HTTP, it'll use HTTP.
If it's using HTTPS, it'll use HTTPS.
Yep.
Yeah.
So really good tip there.
Nice one.
There was another tweet.
Well, actually, yeah, it was a tweet.
But also it was posted somewhere within our hacker circles.
Yeah.
But the Google bug bounty program, VRP program, vulnerability rewards program, whatever you want to call it.
Yep.
That's it.
They released a Burp Suite plugin written in part by one of our buddies, Irby Sam.
Yeah.
And yeah, it's specifically for protobuf testing.
I think it's meant for Google, but you could probably use it for other things.
It's a little bit narrow in terms of how it works if you look into it.
Because I installed it and I was like, why isn't this working?
It looks for application slash proto, I think, in the response header.
But then it will basically decode it and it will make it easy so that you can manipulate protobuf requests without having to have the protofiles.
And yeah, it's really awesome.
I think there's been a lot of different tools that kind of sort of do similar stuff to this kind of, but not very well or not completely.
And yeah, this is really nice to see.
I have a solo episode about protobuf stuff that I still need to record.
Yeah, looking forward to that one, man.
I'll probably include this in there as well.
But yeah, there's a lot of really interesting stuff that you can do with protobuf and that you can use to figure out how protobuf is working.
Yeah, I was, once again, you know, the moat is disappearing here.
You know, I was excited but also a little sad to see them release this because Lupin and I, mostly Lupin really, coded up an extension to do this exact same thing.
Probably with less good results because Google actually has a bunch of resources to allocate to it.
Like three engineers were working on it, including Sam, rather than just what Lupin did late at night, one night.
But, you know, we used this when we were hacking Bard and we found a bunch of great phones with it.
And so definitely increases the accessibility of the Google VRP because one of the biggest problems with hacking on Google is you got to be a protobuf G, you know, to figure all that out.
So really great.
And furthermore, I think this is a great example of how to be a good program.
You know, if you build tools specifically to help hackers hack your program, this takes a lot of work because you have to be aware of how hackers see your program.
You have to be aware of the problems they're running into.
You pretty much have to have tried to hack yourself, right, which is something that so many companies aren't even actually doing.
And then you have to take the initiative to get some engineering done, build out an extension and then give it to the community.
I'm 100% sure that Google will see a ton of ROI on their time for building out this tool because it makes it so much more approachable.
And I would love to see companies that have insight into their own architecture do similar things to help promote their program.
Yeah, absolutely.
At Joel Margolis.
Yes.
Yeah.
So, no, I'd say like I think another good example of this is like SSRF sheriffs, for example.
Like stuff like that that just makes it easier to hack on your program, especially, you know, Google has like for a very long time, it felt like Google had created a lot of things.
They created a very complicated stack that was hard to hack on and they didn't really care about that.
And it was just what it is.
Which is not bad for overall security, but you know.
Right.
But it's really security through obscurity.
And it basically just raised the bar for hacking.
It didn't make it more secure, right?
And so I think by doing this, this helps bring the bar back down a little bit so that it's easier to start hacking on Google stuff and they can still get the security benefit of having people look at their program and being able to hack on it without like doing.
Like if you imagine like a new person comes and like starts to hack on some Google product that uses protobuf, they're going to see this and be like, I have no idea what this is.
It's literally exactly what I did.
It's just binary data.
I don't know what a protobuf is.
They go and look up protobuf.
It's some weird format.
They don't understand the use case.
They don't understand why it is or how it is or any.
And they just give up.
They move on.
They go to a different program.
They go to something that doesn't use it.
And so you need to do stuff like this if you're going to be using it so extensively and have such a large program.
If you want people to be able to hack on your program, you've got to do stuff like this.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I totally agree.
Creating those means to do that, very, very important.
Let's see.
OK, so I guess I'll go ahead and pivot from here into some JS hoisting stuff.
You good with that?
Sure.
Go for it.
I feel like I had something else on that last topic that I wanted to say,
but it escaped me.
So maybe it'll come back later and I'll kind of go from there.
But so I tweeted out something.
It's funny to see my own name in the doc here under the news section.
But I tweeted something out, which I thought was worthy to talk about on the podcast,
because it's a pretty cool exploitation scenario.
And we've been having some chats like this a good bit on Twitter,
just sort of surrounding various XSS scenarios we run into.
And a lot of them have been brought to me by the community,
the critical thinking community just DMing me and being like, hey,
I have a bug here, but I can't fully exploit it.
And sometimes I'll take a look.
Sometimes I won't.
No promises.
But this time I did decide to take a look.
And the scenario was this.
We had an injection.
So I'm going down a path of trying to represent things
from an audio perspective.
It's going to be tricky.
But let's see we had an injection at a place in the JS
where it was x.y, where neither x nor y were defined.
OK?
Can you control them?
No.
You can't control them.
They're not defined.
And then it's a function call.
So it's calling the function x.y.
The first parameter is a one.
There's a comma.
And then you are injecting.
OK?
And you can inject anything you want except for script text.
You have to stay inside the script.
Right?
How do you get this to resolve?
Because as soon as it reads the line,
it's going to say x is undefined or y is undefined.
Can't read a property on undefined error.
And then your code is never going to run.
And so I was looking at this.
I was like, I know that there's a way to exploit this.
I can't figure out what it was.
And I tried actually the solution that ended up working.
But I was missing one stupid little piece.
And the answer to this problem is something called JS
wasting.
Have you heard of JS wasting, Joel?
I don't know if I've heard of the term,
but if you explain it to me, I might have heard of it.
Yeah.
So the term is JS wasting.
And it's essentially the concept that functions in JS
defined using and some other objects as well,
but mostly for this case functions,
defined using the function keyword,
despite where they are in the flow,
will be hoisted to the top of the script execution flow.
So if you define a function at the very bottom
using the function keyword of a script tag,
and you call that function above where
that function is defined, it'll work.
Because the function definition is getting moved up
to the top of the script.
So in this scenario, what we were able to do
was define the function x.
And what that would do is it would hoist the definition
up to the top.
And now the variable x now contains a valid function.
OK?
So when you try to access the property y on x,
you don't get an error, but you get y is undefined.
Then it will attempt to call the undefined y because of the function
call.
And when it does that, it will parse the parameters that
are being passed into that function.
And at that point, when it parses the parameters,
you can do a function call in the parameters themselves.
And that will get executed before it attempts to call y,
which will inevitably fail because you can't call undefined.
And in that way, we were able to get arbitrary script execution
and pop it into an XSS because of this concept called JS wasting.
So I wanted to shout that out there because we're big fans
of that kind of crazy edge fringe JavaScript shit here on the pod.
And I wasn't even sure.
Yeah.
I feel like most people haven't heard of it.
So I would have been surprised if you had heard of that, Joel.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
I was just testing some things around.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN He's got a handheld mic,
and he's trying to type and speak into the.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
I was testing some things around this to see
if there's a better way.
And I think there might be without having
to break out of the whole thing.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN This is like classic Joel
nerd sniped shit right here.
OK.
All right, Joel, rein it in.
Bring it back to the pod.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Okay.
What I was going to say is, though.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN He says, OK, he's still
freaking looking at it.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN I am still freaking looking at it.
I was just going to.
OK.
Yeah, so the JS hoisting thing, it seems that,
so context is important, right?
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Basically, my thought was,
like, maybe you could do this without having to break out
of the function.
But even if you define x within the parameters,
it doesn't work.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Right.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN It never gets evaluated
because it fails right in the beginning.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Right.
So, like, you tweeted out a similar, like,
an XSS challenge, like, a while ago.
And it had to do with, essentially, in JavaScript,
there's a behavior where you can use commas to provide multiple
statements and you can assign variables to the last variable,
the last thing that is returned in that comma sequence.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN All right, Joel.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN So before we get further nerd sniped on this, let's move to
the next thing.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Because actually, as far as nerd sniping goes, I was just kind
of researching this this morning on a whim.
And I am just, I just love CSP bypass shit, dude.
I don't know why.
It just feels great.
And this is so cool.
Once again, our boy Johan is just dropping all sorts of amazing shit.
This one was actually in the Cool Research channel on the Discord, which is a goldmine
of Cool Research.
I'm so glad we built that channel.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah, for real.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN I've been reading everything that comes through there.
And I've seen so many things that I've missed somehow.
So really appreciate everyone contributing to that.
One of the things that's dropped in there was this crazy, yeah, it's the first one, Joel,
octagon.net, this crazy write up on how to do some CSP bypassing.
So what's happening here is, in the specific example, it's using a WordPress endpoint that
has JSONP compatibility, right?
So you can bypass CSP on a WordPress site.
Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN This one is so cool.
But the JSONP endpoint that has JSONP compatibility, right?
So you can bypass CSP on a WordPress site.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN But the JSONP endpoint that's there, it doesn't allow you to use commas.
It doesn't allow you to use things.
So it's a secure JSONP endpoint.
It doesn't allow you to write your own code, essentially, in the callback, right?
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Mm-hmm.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN It just allows you to use dots and letters, which is what you see with a lot of fixed JSONP endpoints.
They don't want you to be able to write alert, you know, open bracket, close bracket, and then just be able to run arbitrary code there.
But this guy figured out a way to actually use this still to bypass CSP, okay?
So essentially, what he figured out how to do was, so in a JSONP endpoint, obviously, it's going to call the function with its own contents at the end of the day.
Here, Joel, let me actually send you, I can send you the actual endpoint really quickly here.
So you have an example of what I'm looking at.
Hold on just a sec.
I want you to be able to see this, because it's just so...
Okay, so here's an example of the actual, I'm going to send it to you on, I'm going to put it in the Riverside chat, because it's, it's, I've got Discord closed, so it doesn't go up.
I was going to say, I also did.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Do you see that?
I do see that.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Okay, so go to that, go to that, you can see that.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Go to that, go to that URL.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yep.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN So you see how it says, attacker input, and then it's got the function call and then the data inside of it, right?
This is classic JSONP callback, okay?
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN Yeah.
JOEL HALLERYSCHEKERMANN What he does here is instead, he, so we can only inject characters and dots.
He builds out this flow, okay?
Let me see if I can find it.
It says, so you can open window, you can do window.opener.whatever.
And then select a button on the parent tab, right?
Via that.
And then call the click function with that.
And it doesn't matter the context, right?
And then what you're going to have to do, you're going to have to open this page up via a window.open from your attacker-controlled page, right?
Now it's open, it's two separate frames.
Redirect the attacker-controlled page to the target domain where you have a button that you want to get clicked, right?
Like delete account, okay?
So now the two pages, the two tabs that are open are same origin, right?
And then what you do is you trigger the XSS and it will go back to window.opener when it calls the XSS.
This is the same origin now, so it can reach back up through window.opener and call the .click function on a specific button that you want, like delete account, right?
So you can actually weaponize this to reach back up to the different tab and trigger it with just the use of window.opener, .body, .firstelement, sibling, you know, define that whole flow out.
So this is the same kind of where from attacker page you open the victim page and then you're going cross tab using the same origin to abuse behavior within the page.
Similar concept to what we were talking about earlier, but a little bit different because after you open the tab with the attacker, you know, from the attacker-controlled page, you remove the attacker-controlled context from, you know, piece out of there.
You redirect that opener to, or you redirect yourself to the victim page.
Right, and just by the way it behaves it, you know, yeah.
Yeah, and then window.opener still points back to that frame, which is so cool.
I guess that makes sense, yeah, because it's the same.
It's like the same tab instance or whatever.
Yeah, they're in the same sort of tab group and window.opener is pointing back to that frame, but now that frame is same origin.
And so you're not going to get an error if you try to execute window.opener.content.document.body.child.child.chile.click, right?
And then it'll just call that function with the CSB bypass, click on the button and cause essentially a CSRF to happen.
Yeah.
Is that not absolutely breathtaking?
It's a really interesting exploit.
I love that kind of creativity where, you know, we've talked about this before, but browsers are adding a lot of security features that make it very difficult to exploit.
Even like if something is vulnerable, it's difficult to exploit it.
Like you can see the vulnerability, but it's just difficult, like just due to security mechanisms in place.
And these new types of attacks that are coming out now, a lot of them are utilizing even within that secure environment, they're utilizing just like baseline behavior in order to abuse it in order to make it do stuff that you want, like click buttons.
Like it's almost like a whole new CSRF in a sense.
Yeah.
I mean, same thing that's happening that I've ranted about all the time with client side path traversals.
Stuff moves over to single page applications and yeah.
Yeah.
These new sort of frontier of vulnerabilities are coming forth and it's really exciting.
It's very hard for me to be honest.
I'm surprised you got it, Joel.
It's very hard for me to do this vulnerability justice over the audio medium because you really need to be able to kind of see what is happening.
So I'm definitely going to link this one.
If you're going to read anything that we did today, if you're going to do anything that we have talked about today, join the CTPB podcast discord because this stuff pops up there.
But if you're going to do two things, the second thing should be octagon.net write up on bypassing CSP using WordPress by abusing same origin method execution.
It's the title of the research.
Super rad about how they do this sort of frame origin manipulation and then are able to weaponize just the calling of a function to actually trigger that functionality within the confines of CSP.
Super inspiring.
Super cool.
Yeah.
Really love that.
And those JSONP gadgets are actually everywhere.
You know, a JSONP gadget that allows you to actually run arbitrary code, those are still there, but they're disappearing.
These are everywhere.
And so really cool to see someone actually be able to exploit that.
Yeah, totally.
I mean, the CSP bypass tool is always like, you know, oh, JSONP.
And there was just this discussion about this too, where people were like, I don't really see JSONP use very much.
And you were like, actually, I see it all the time.
It's everywhere.
I just used it recently.
Yeah.
So much legacy stuff in there.
And especially if people like will star their own domain in, if they have a, you know, a blog, every company has a blog on their main domain, right?
That uses WordPress.
There's WordPress endpoints that use JSONP just like this.
And you can't run arbitrary code, but using this, you can actually get a CSERF with your, you know, sort of half XSS.
And this will also help prove that there's impact to XSSs that are blocked by CSP in a lot of cases as well.
It just takes time and dedication to actually break through it.
So on that note, another one of my favorite pieces of research released in 2018 by Wallarm.
Wallarm.
W-A-L-L-A-R-M.
Yeah.
So when I first saw this, I was like, wow, this is so genius.
And I figured it'd be fitting here because we're already talking about CSP.
This is a scenario where you have XSS and you're able to execute, you know, your alert because unsafe inline is allowed on the CSP policy.
But you can't run arbitrary code either because of a link limitation or because the CSP prevents you from reaching out to another domain in any way.
And you can't really X fill anything besides maybe like a page redirection or something like that, which might mess up your flow of the attack.
This is a really cool bypass that uses sort of proxying of sorts to bypass CSP.
And so the scenario is you've got a content security policy with unsafe inline allowed and you want to X fill data.
And what you do is you write a script which will iframe in another page on that same domain.
So once again, we're same origin.
We're using origin related stuff here.
You can reach into that iframe, control the content.
And you look for a page like a CSS file or a JS file or a PNG file, any sort of file that does not have the content security policy header.
And every time I've looked for that, I've found it because people use these, you know, reverse proxies nowadays where they're like reaching into, you know, an S3 bucket to store their assets and that sort of thing.
Everyone's doing this and the CSP header is really not globally defined across the whole scope.
And when it's not, you can use that non CSP header having page as a proxy for communication out.
So you iframe in that page and then you can control the script execution on that iframe didn't page and that page does not have CSP limitations.
And so then you can use that to arbitrarily grab content that you want to load from, you know, your, your, your website, pull it down and then execute it on the parent context as well.
Because once again, same origins, we can, you know, load a script on that.
So in this scenario, you're basically, you're using, let's say reflected XSS in line on, on the victim domain to iframe a same origin domain on the victim that is missing CSP for something.
And then you use your XSS to change the contents of that frame to load.
To include a script from a different location.
Right.
And because it has no CSP in the frame, then you can include an attacker script which has free access to do whatever it wants.
Exactly.
And you can talk to the parent frame because of the same origin.
Yeah.
And that can exfill data.
It can load arbitrary scripts, that sort of thing.
You know, a lot of times when you're trying to show impact for an XSS, they say, hey, please prove arbitrary execution of JS, right?
Not just alert.
Show me that you can run any script, right?
How do you usually show that?
So for me, you know, a lot of times I'm going to run any script.
So for me, you know, a lot of times if you can pull from a domain, that's great.
But a lot of times when they're asking for this, it's in a length limited context, right?
Where you would have a hard time fetching data and exfilling it, right?
But in a scenario like this, if you have one limited.
You can sort of break out because you can include your, yeah.
Exactly.
And then as soon as you include that script inside the child tag or the child iframe, then you're loading from a domain.
And then you've got all the JS execution you need to do a multi-step attack and really exfil some important data.
And you can also do it blindly, right?
You don't need, the victim doesn't need to know that that's happening.
Yeah.
And so really cool way to bypass CSP from Wallerm.
We'll link that technique down in the show notes.
Very helpful.
Do you find that a lot of this iframe stuff is harder to do with the X-frame options stuff nowadays?
It most certainly is, yeah.
But the cool thing about this though is that if it's missing the CSP header, it's probably also missing the X-frame options header.
Because those are normally grouped in the same sort of reverse proxy header appending rule.
So I still see this from time to time.
And actually a technique like this, not exactly like this, but similar to this, helped me score a 70k XSS one time.
And it was a heck of a bug.
It's quite XSS.
It was.
It's crazy to me that my highest bounty is in XSS, but it was affecting, I mean, it was a company where the client side is everything, you know?
Yeah.
And where they really have to keep their client side tight.
And if they make a problem, it affects a ton of people.
Yeah.
So really, really excited to make sure people know about this technique as well because it's near and dear to my heart.
Yeah, that's awesome.
All right.
We are, what, we're like an hour and a half in?
Yeah, we're pushing it, man.
An hour and a half in.
We just made it through the news.
So we should probably call it here.
Yeah, we should call it here.
I'm just going to say this for those of you, and we'll cover a little bit more in the future as well on this,
but OpenID and OAuth stuff, extremely interesting.
Impact is everywhere.
There's a lot of standardized endpoints from the OpenID standard that will allow you to do a lot better recon on your targets
and try to get access to areas of the applications that you may not have access to because of permissioning problems
by knowing OpenID really well.
So hopefully we'll deliver you some content in the future, diving into that a little bit deeper.
But for now, just know that that is coming because we'll do some reading on it beforehand.
I see what your cursor is on.
I see what your cursor is on, and you just left them with quite a teaser.
I did, man.
I did.
There's some great stuff there.
And I will say I'll be the first to say that doing a podcast on an extremely technical field is extremely challenging.
And I think I'm probably subpar at taking extremely technical content and condensing it into just words
and conveying that picture to the listener in a way that is easily comprehensible.
That's something that I'm working on.
But if you guys actually do the homework after the episodes and maybe even before the episodes when I give you a heads up like this,
the stuff that I'm talking about will start making a lot more sense.
And you'll get a lot more value out of the podcast.
If something's really not clear, what I'd recommend is go to the show notes, open the link that we're talking about,
and either side by side or in your headphones, listen to us talk about it as you're reading through the article,
and it will probably make significantly more sense because that's a lot of what we do as well as we have them both open as we talk about it.
So, yeah.
And I think we're talking about concepts that might not be clear.
Like verbally, we're not great at explaining it.
But then if you just read through it, you'll it'll make sense.
Yeah, 100%.
And I think, Joel, as well, you do a good job of sort of teasing it out and making me re-explain it and re-simplifying the words once I've kind of...
Also, part of it is because like you'll... the way you approach things often is like from the hacker's perspective.
Yeah.
And this is a common mistake as well. Like report writing, this happens all the time where hackers like explain stuff from a hacker's perspective instead of from like a fresh perspective.
And you have like a lot of like side data in there that like makes sense to you but doesn't make sense to anybody else.
So you have to like...
Yeah.
It's difficult. It's a skill for sure.
Well, I'm glad I brought a program manager on as well to help me get this, you know, sort of context included.
I'm solid life choices getting you on this pod, Joel. I love this man.
Awesome.
All right. Cool.
Well, that's a wrap. Yeah?
Yeah, that's the wrap.
All right. That's the pod.
Peace.